hallo leute wir sind zurück in berlin
nach unserer reihe
es ist schweinekalt hier in berlin
es ist wahnsinnig kalt ist null grad für
die die nicht in celsius rechnen
das ist der gefrierpunkt also da wo
alles einfrieren wird janosch wie fühlst
du dich in zurück in berlin sehr gut
heute zum ersten mal zu
hast du gesehen dass ich mir ein
mikrofon halter gebastelt
das ist ein fun wender fahnenbänder ist
etwas womit man in der pfanne sachen
wendet wir gehen da kurz und block und
jannis liest uns die neuesten fragen vor
davy jones schreibt hallo karriere vor
weihnachten nach weihnachten oder
irgendwann mal in die schweiz kommt es
wäre mir eine ehre euch jene schweiz
begrüssen zu dürfen und eventuell
zusammen mit euch eine episode zu drehen
ansonsten werde ich bei weihnachten in
berlin auftauchten und euch ja bitte
besucht uns doch davy schöne grüße in
die schweiz wir kommen sehr gerne in die
schweiz
wir waren ja auch letztes jahr schon in
der schweiz dort hat es uns gut gefallen
dass ein symbol ist immer richtig
richtig teuer ist in der schweiz
nichtsdestotrotz möchten wir dich bitten
wenn du lust hast uns einzuladen
dann schreibt uns bitte in unser
formular haben ein formular letzte woche
den link findet ihr unten in der
beschreibung des videos und es haben
sich auch schon ganz viele leute
gemeldet warum machen wir das weil wir
mittlerweile so viele einladungen
bekommen haben dass es schwierig ist das
alles per e-mail und in den kommentaren
zu sortieren und mit diesem formular
haben wir dann eine excel tabelle
wo wir direkt sehen kann wer uns
eingeladen hat das macht es für uns wäre
viel einfacher und wir können sachen
sortieren das heißt wenn uns zum
beispiel fünf leute aus der schweiz
einladen dann ist das ein guter grund
das hier in die schweiz kommen und wir
freuen uns bittet rein wenn ihr uns
einladen möchten als schule als
studenten oder privat schreibt es hier
unten in unserer google formular dann
schaffst du noch was die nächste frage
ist vom zombie markt gibt
kraftvoll leistung wie sieht mein glas
in mailand barcelona sid was sagst du ja
mich ist es das wert oder nicht nach
irland zu fahren ja auf jeden fall eine
ganz kleine klasse besuchen wenn ihr uns
mögt und unseres material benutzt werden
die auch darüber berichten und wir
werden davon mit anderen teilen und in
dem sinne ist es immer eine riesige
veranstaltung für uns und für uns sollte
sowieso die frage ist wahrscheinlich nur
wo kriegen wir besorgen wir uns geld für
die fahrkarte aber so warten wir
internet aber sobald wir das geld für
die fahrkarte haben sind wir schon
unterwegs schreibt uns in das formular
wenn du uns einladen möchte dass
gekündigt versprechen dass wir sofort
kommt aber vielleicht melden sich ja
noch mehr leute aus irland und sobald
wir irgendwie mehrere einladungen haben
zwei drei oder vier kommen wir sofort
darüber geflogen von berlin ist es nicht
weit und so teuer ist es auch eigentlich
gar nicht was ist die nächste frage du
hast unsere lieblings kommen meint
persönlichen lieblings kommentar der
woche oder sogar des monats geschrieben
war donnerstag in german fragst du auf
einem kanal der isi german heißt und in
seiner beschreibung schreibt dass wir
leuten helfen beim deutsch lernen aber
in diesen zeiten kann man ja das
offensichtliche gar nicht oft genug
sagen deshalb hier noch mal für dich
wir unterrichten deutsch bei youtube
diesmal vorsichtiger was du da liest und
versucht das zu verstehen
ich finde meinen länder total toll wie
ich das mikrofon wende wie ein spiegel
ein
die leute hat sich trotzdem berichten
dass machen also rosig sagt weigel
firmen sony center becking von manni
slogans wie sie die usa hatten wir auf
jeden fall ist ist sozialist mentalität
notwendig war daher mit dicken oder ich
hab mich verlesen hat amerika nie
endenden beck ich mach die european yao
c myc das ist keine europäische sache
das ist einfach das internet und im
internet gibt es auch kapitalismus aber
auch eine andere mentalität im internet
gibt es vieles umsonst und so gibt es
auch unsere videos umsonst aber
natürlich freuen wir uns wenn wir auch
dafür etwas zurückbekommen und das kann
alles mögliche sein das kann eine nette
e mail sein
ein netter kommentar das kann eine
einladung sein in den usa wurden wir
fast jeden abend von anderen menschen
eingeladen die in sein programm mögen
und das ist auch ja wie so eine art
bezahlung für das was wir tun und gibt
uns unglaublich viel energie aber es
kann eben auch geld sein und wir
verdienen mit unseren videos geld sonst
würden wir das auch nicht machen zum
beispiel in form von werbung und
mittlerweile bekommen wir die hälfte
unseres geldes auch durch spenden und
das hat nichts damit zu tun dass wir
geldgeil sind sondern dass wir von
irgendwas leben müssen und wenn wir
davon leben könnten würden wir diese
sachen gar nicht machen also eine ganz
einfache rechnung eigentlich und ja wir
fragen leute nach geld ich habe auch
schon youtuber gesehen die das ziemlich
dreist und ziemlich plump machen und den
meisten fällen funktioniert es daneben
auch nicht aber wenn man es nicht macht
und leute einfach fragt etwas zurück zu
geben für das was wir investieren dann
ist das hat er sich mit sozialismus zu
tun
es ist eigentlich kapitalistischer
arbeit ist ja auch nicht umsonst und wie
auch nicht ja nicht was guckst du deine
hände schon eingefahren
nicht alles gut nächste frage ok anna
kasseckert fragt hallo ich habe eine
frage und zwar ist es einfach als
ausländer in deutschland einen job zu
finden
ganz ganz ganz bezahlt meine
pfannenwender hand wechseln schnell
anstrengend
ghana hat uns geschrieben sie fragt ob
es schwierig ist als ausländer in
deutschland einen job zu finden
diese frage haben natürlich viele viele
von euch lerne deutsch weil ihr gerne in
deutschland studieren oder eben arbeiten
möchte
diese freiheit kann man nicht generell
beantworten
mit manchen jobs manchen fächern und
manchen jobs ist es einfach in
deutschland einen job zu finden zum
beispiel als ingenieur oder auch als
arzt werdet ihr ziemlich schnell in
deutschland was hinten denke ich also
das ist meine persönliche erfahrung auch
von meinen freunden die ich kenne
mit anderen fächern sage ich mal jetzt
wenn ihr soziologie oder geschichte
studiert hat da ist es schon in
deutschland schwer einen job zu finden
ich habe zum beispiel geschichte und
soziologie studiert aber nicht
ausgeschlossen erna in deinem fall hast
du geschrieben du hast wirtschaft
studiert und du hast vor eine
doktorarbeit in deutschland zu machen
das würde ich dir auf jeden fall
empfehlen also wenn du die sprache gut
beherrscht man kann natürlich auch
wirtschaftswissenschaften in englisch
studieren aber da gibt es weniger
möglichkeiten
deswegen würde ich auf jeden fall
empfehlen dass du ja so gut deutsch
lernst oder vielleicht schon kannst also
c1 niveau hass der mitte auf deutsch
studieren kannst und ich sage mal jeder
eigentlich in jedem fach und jeder der
sich anstrengt wird das irgendwie
schaffen also ich will euch nur
ermutigen versucht in deutschland zu
studieren
ihr werdet es bestimmt nicht bereuen sie
sehr schlimm sagt hallo hier sehen sie
cool und du bist auch voll hübsch aber
warum ist immer noch in deutschland viel
viel rassismus warum gibt es in
deutschland viel rassismus
ja also rassismus gibt es leider also
damit müssen wir auch leben das ist das
gibt und wenn du wissen wir jetzt warum
das so ist kann ich dir natürlich meine
erklärung liefern ich denke dass es ich
denke ich denke dass wir in einer sehr
komplexen welt leben und das ist
eigentlich der grund warum es rassismus
west gibt das ist muss sie eigentlich
ein konzept das einfach sachen
vereinfacht und menschen auf bestimmte
eigenschaften reduziert um das mal kurz
zu sagen und ich denke dass viele leute
heutzutage wo die welt irgendwie
komplexer wird durch das internet
erfahren wir auch immer alles rund um
die uhr sofort wenn es passiert in allen
ländern der welt und das überfordert
viele menschen dass es schwierig und das
ist auch nicht das hat nicht unbedingt
damit etwas zu tun dass menschen dumm
sind sondern das ist einfach schwierig
wir leben in schwierigen zeiten und
rassismus ist einfach ein konzept das
nicht schön ist das überhaupt nicht gut
ist dass viele schwierige viele
furchtbare ausbildung
und ich denke dass viele leute verstehen
das eben nicht dass sachen komplex sind
viele leute verstehen nicht dass es
muslime gibt die terroristen sind und
muslime gibt die keine terroristen sind
viele leute verstehen nicht dass es
deutsche gibt die nazis waren und
deutsche gab die keine nazis waren viele
leute verstehen nicht dass es amerikaner
gibt es die donald trump wählen und
andere amerikaner die nicht dort
schaffen und viele menschen verstehen
auch nicht dass es mexikaner gibt die
donald trump wellen aber alle diese
sachen existieren in unserer welt und
wir müssen uns damit auseinandersetzen
dass die welt komplexes und das ist
viele verschiedene menschen mit
verschiedenen ideen und dass nicht alles
schwarz und weiß ist und rassisten
können das eben nicht oder wollen dass
mich viele leute vallendar auch darauf
ein drauf rein denke ich das ist zum
beispiel bei der usa wahl zu sehen
donald trump ist ein mensch der
rassistische ideen und rassistische
gedanken äußert das muss man ganz klar
so sagen
und trotzdem glaube ich nicht dass 5
der amerikaner rassisten sind
dass sie vielleicht das ist ihnen
vielleicht egal ist was er gesagt hat
und sie ihn aus anderen gründen wählen
das ist für mich sehr traurig finde es
schade aber wir müssen damit leben und
wir müssen auch weiter daran ändern dass
sich diese konzepte nicht um die welt
tragen und dazu kann ich nur euch alle
ermutigen es gibt viele schöne projekte
die man machen kann man soll den dialog
suchen mann soll mit menschen reden und
das dürfen wir niemals aufgeben
amen das habe mein wort für slaughter ja
und du merkst schon an der länge der
antwort von gar die dass das problem
wirklich komplex ist und ich würde auch
gerne mit dir darüber sprechen ich bin
selber ausländer der in deutschland lebt
und ich habe da meine eigene meinung und
eine eine sache sage ich nur in
deutschland gibt es wirklich sehr wenig
rassismus auf der anderen seite wenn du
anders aussieht wenn du ansprichst
augenfarbe hast keine ahnung muss damit
rechnen dass du auch besetzer
schwieriger haben wirst wie sollen ganz
normaler standard stellen quasi nicht
die aufmerksamkeit auf sich zieht das
dann auch nur einmal aber grundsätzlich
egal welche hautfarbe egal welche rasse
du bist in deutschland findest du immer
freunde und immer deine eigene leute und
in deutschland genauso wie überall gibt
es auch viele dumme menschen
die kann man aber marginalisieren man
muss nicht an die denken sie bedeuten
nicht viel in diesem land und fallen
auch nicht auf in diesem land wenn du
jetzt nicht unbedingt irgendwo hin einst
lebte wer verrückter hund fügte aussage
ja danke für eure ganzen kommentare
diese episode ist etwas lang geworden
wir müssen nächstes mal wieder wenigere
fragen auswählen danke fürs zuschauen
und falls ihr falls ihr lust habt dürft
ihr uns gerne unterstützen wir freuen
uns immer auf eure spenden und ihr
kriegt auch etwas zurück dafür ist es
kein sozialismus sondern wir geben euch
etwas neues etwas zurück das geht hier
unten bei petschel danke fürs süße und
bis nächste woche
das
heute auf
unser widerstand
allerdings